- A lot of people write into the show
with parenting questions.
So we thought that it might be fun
for Tyler and I to answer some
of those, maybe we'll fail,
we don't know.
Are you cool with it?
You don't have a choice.
- Okay, good.
(laughing)
I'm just wondering if I'm
gonna answer as Tyler or Madea,
but we'll go ahead.
- Okay.
- We'll figure it out.
- You can, either one can answer.
- Okay.
- I'm excited
at the opportunity of either one.
Okay, so let's see the first one.
So how do you deal with
having to watch the
(laughing)
same movie or hear the same
song 27 times in a row?
- When your kid's very young.
- Yeah.
- How'd you deal with it?
- My kids still do it,
five and seven, they still,
- They still do.
- I've seen Encanto, I
love Encanto luckily,
thank you in Encanto
people, but I can recite it.
- Yeah.
- Yup.
- And then we get in the car
and I'm not allowed to play anything else
other than the soundtrack.
- And you're and you're okay?
- I'm okay.
I can compartmentalize.
It's crazy.
- That's good that you
can compartmentalize
- I can.
- but I'm gonna
tell you the answer.
- Okay.
- Weed gummies.
(laughing)
Weed gummies.
I'm telling you every time you see
every,
- Weed.
- weed, weed.
- I love it.
- Every time you see it
you'll see something else and you go, wow.
This movie is so deep.
- It's like watching O in Vegas
You see something different every time
there's so much happening,
you're like wow.
- Wait, you like O too.
- I love O.
- Did you see it on a gummy?
- I didn't no.
- Oh, okay.
You gotta see--
- I didn't see it on a gummy.
- You like O, I like O,
we gotta get married.
- Yeah.
- We gotta get married, I'm telling you.
- But it is, like I feel like
you don't even have to
be on a gummy to see O.
You go watch O and I'm
like, I missed that,
this whole section like
the last time I was here,
what's 'cause there's so much happening.
- It's the most incredible
Cirque du Soleil show
I've ever seen.
Everybody that goes to Vegas,
I was like, you've gotta see O.
- It's so good, yes.
- Yeah it's really good.